[Music]
well good news
we might have a chance to get
Brandon Shaban Mark Harley on the show
and here's why
because they're doing this frag out
podcast it only has 29 subscribers
I swear to God what yeah yeah look
the frag out party it's a bigger podcast
on like iTunes or something
whoa
I don't know why given the benefit of
the doubt 35 views Brendan Schaub Mark
Harley welcome to the fragall podcast
for having us man uh this is absolutely
insanity but it's it's a good Insanity
I'm super excited
um we Brendan you uh you lost your uh
your your Satchel there in the Uber it's
a fanny pack okay well I was trying to
not no it's very gay I mean Indiana
Jones had a satchel so I mean yeah he's
a badass his was a satchel mine says
Mark Harley is in love with him and I'm
not trying big gay lion has a big gay
Crush because I want you to look at his
eyes like like vvv love yeah [ __ ]
Dreamweaver is playing yes
[Music]
have we confirmed have you guys
confirmed that Mark Harley is a real
person yeah CGI well yeah the only
reason why though is because we did see
him in that old bet Show when he was
smaller so yeah okay he is a real person
now was he made in a lab I don't know
yes but I do know he is a human being I
don't haven't made he was made in a
Russian Lab at printed Schwab's [ __ ]
request yes well I don't know we will uh
we were going to combine the genes of a
lion with a homosexual man
why we have crossed the lion with Fabio
with homosexual male it will be glorious
uh
uh
what was it at one point we stopped
asking if we could and we should have
started asking if we should if we should
men will want to be him women will want
to be him
very funny
all right let's frag out straight up
Saint Laurent full-blown far left don't
worry frag out we'll make sure this
episode gets a bunch of views Satchel I
mean yeah they have 33 ratings on Apple
okay so it's it's not a big it's not a
big podcast either then merch why is is
this a favor what is he doing I have a
feeling that he probably helped him out
because this guy's one of those guys
that owns mortgagenerds.com is what it
looks like I'm looking at his wall so
he's kind of do like a uh what what's
his face um
uh the wrestling guy uh Conrad thing oh
chat me up here Brandon
Brandon you got hit in the head 45 times
now you're telling me that didn't affect
your uh your brain why are you doing why
are you doing uh why are you doing a
podcast is because your Joe Rogan's
friend chat me up on that
hey uh you know what I'm sorry but
Brendan how are you such a Mush Mouth
now keep in mind that's I'm a guy asking
you my father-in-law is Ric Flair
gotta have that drip dog yeah that trip
is a Pete bootage Satchel uh
booty gauge
you can't get anything correct now Tama
Glenn you don't blend in an Appleton
with that I just want to throw it out I
don't blend in anywhere in Appleton
anytime we walk in stores that everyone
goes you know you know you blend in
printing at a [ __ ] Factory
[Laughter]
you've got a [ __ ] I don't know I've
called them everything at this point at
the GE [ __ ] Factory
[Laughter]
you're the floor model at a [ __ ]
Factory
scratching deadly
from around here already I'm like what
gave it away wait yeah what what uh what
am I wearing that doesn't say Wisconsin
on it it's like what gave it away the
fashion you know well
the Delia thing the Delia impression can
you pull I I want to point out I'll get
the clip it all right yeah just you can
keep Flags I want to compare this side
part kind of fits in a you know he's got
he's got the he's got the Plaid on he's
got he's got the muscles he got not the
hair the hair doesn't match she has
neither one of us fit in here dies of an
Angel and the is he is he hitting
delicate is he hitting on him Autumn
scented hair of a of a beautiful lion
you look ridiculous out here and they
you know they do think we're two gay men
I mean why is it the way you dress act
or [ __ ]
all right I posted it in Show links okay
damn it Royce that was funny we keep
saying it's he's ripping off the lead
he's ripping off Sasso more than Delia
okay uh you might be right let's see
he's showing she said yeah I put in show
all right let's see
oh the furniture oh you haven't got much
to spam
pass what I'm moving up with yeah
all right good so um
how was Australia it was nice yeah yeah
have you been down there no I've never
been down there talk less loud yeah
we're right what do they call they call
lobsters bugs out there yeah they do
well they're in the restaurant family
shut the [ __ ] up about animals I'm just
talking about Australia and he was so
happy to go yeah oh why do we call them
bugs because uh yeah I'm gonna tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tone Oh okay what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that
boxing you've been doing wow that is
what he's doing and it's on the fighter
and the kid Clips so he knows
like that's a one of his what's one of
the most famous clips from fighter in
the kid and uh I almost called him
fighter in the clip foo fighter and the
kid
um that's one of their biggest Clips so
he's watched that clip before and that's
burrowed into his brain by the way
you're thinking of this thing in the
[ __ ] that's a different show the cling
and The Sting the [ __ ] in the sting
and just because we're holding hands
right mean wow can I point something out
Marsh because Marsh and I've been doing
this a really long time
I want you to look at the microphones of
these three men and tell me who the
[ __ ] is
oh
who got who got the who got the desktop
the one that's not even usually in that
studio probably had to go get out of a
box in a clear container somewhere yeah
that you're like hang on hang on I have
one and then that's the that's the
classic Royce move yep I've done it back
in the day he used to be like oh man I
got two guests today what do I do
digging around through a closet getting
an old shitty Behringer Mike is running
on a tabletop thing here look [ __ ] it
we're only over an hour it's [ __ ]
it's fine this will be fine this will
work
but you're right it is the [ __ ] mic the
least important guy I always get well
the only one least less important than
this is the guy that has to hold his
bike true when they have like another
it's like all right here this is just a
mic the guy's sitting the guy's sitting
on the couch like this with his yes when
his legs crossed yeah
good thing about Wisconsin all the women
are just as big as this hair they are
thick girls I mean like I'm I'm known as
a thick man and no you're not Tom Segura
was and then you set it to mine now
La yeah yeah in Wisconsin I was like oh
you're scared are you okay do you need
to eat nobody's doing that that's a
terrible premise your jokes are stupid
and you should feel sad every single day
you wake up and look in the mirror and
realize I am the least funniest man to
ever exist
that's pretty much it but I need some
cheese curds I'm like no I was gonna
tell you guys to get some cheese curds
last night we haven't tried them last
night we're gonna start them with food
because then we get real we come from
sure to pick up the guy real fast
you want that you want to go
I don't think so very well done wait all
right no where were we at the bar
afterwards it was called Basils Basils
is great yeah we have great Burgers yeah
I'm gonna skip ahead tired but and then
just hey let me guess you're not
attractive no not at all that's how this
goes shot in the dark Goose not attract
them this is my new Brendan thing I
don't like this now so the only thing I
can come up with for why the [ __ ] he
went all the way out to Wisconsin to do
a goddamn show that has 33 Subs
is he has a [ __ ] stand-up uh he's
he's booked in November
or hear me out hear me out dude hear me
out hear me out
the guy that does the podcast the guy
you mean the guy the guy the guy the guy
the guy the guy the guy that does the
podcast probably runs the comedy club
and he's probably starting a podcast
this happens a lot we've seen Mercy oh
story is the local country right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense yep
right there and then I you know I I and
I started getting into more comedy like
throughout you know the military so it's
pronounced comedy if you want to think
correctly yes but your own followers but
but even though your own followers in
the Instagram algorithm the new
algorithm which I'm not hating on them
for this do you but obviously Instagram
wants to make money so the way they make
money so let's take me for instance they
go all right you have whatever one okay
you're pretty [ __ ] stupid you'll just
do whatever we say right you're dumb
you're a dumb guy right 0.3 million
followers now you're not going to reach
all 1.3 our new algorithm if you want to
reach even half of that even a third of
that you have to pay us now so if you're
going to do a post you have to boost it
in order
I just he uh I thought I I didn't know
and I didn't know if you knew this
either but uh last summer uh because I'm
a huge archery guy I love archery I've
been are you because when when I look at
you you don't look it's like a huge
archery guy well this guy's a huge
anything he becomes a part of so
I'm getting into archery last two years
um I'm a part of HHA Sports okay
skipping
top up
30 retweets because it's different right
and the algorithm pushes that bro I
skipped in 20 minutes I skipped it 20
minutes and they're still talking about
their Twitter their Twitter interactions
oh [ __ ] but everybody's here but I
consider it a powerful minority I think
the cool thing is that like
most people the vast majority are still
I I meet people with common sense and we
all think the same things we all know I
really hate this fake intelligent
inflection in his voice I'm real sick of
it yeah it sounds nothing like his rap
voice kidless things are ridiculous drag
voice look at this and the reasonable
things are reasonable and there is a
powerful minority in these tech
companies and remember when he said he
cocked because black people wouldn't
black guys wouldn't dress like women so
he said he'd take the bullet remember
that oh that's right yeah people forget
how big Fear Factor is yeah he works for
the UFC Rogan of course Rogan we got to
talk about it
yeah yeah I didn't know that yeah well
ESPN
so so their deal with ESPN so the UFC
has to answer to his house because
Mickey Mouse owns ESPN I get an email I
log into the UFC app or ESPN app to
watch UFC it's like there was no Brendan
actually believes that Mickey Mouse
probably runs Disney World well he's
yeah probably we're in the NFL it
probably came from money there's a good
point there's a good chance they came
from money but there's also a good
chance who was an NFL player like last
year that was camped out or like he was
homeless and then he yeah a receiver for
the Chiefs
stage and crutches man he crushes and
then Mark was filmed oh my God man bro I
don't know how this podcast only has 30
[ __ ] Subs to it it's [ __ ] riveting
wow bro this is like this is like
watching [ __ ] pink dry at a [ __ ]
Factory
we should have just watched the [ __ ]
Factory the idea for animals so this is
I mean there's a historic uh about a
historic meaning of a party in
Whitewater Wisconsin I was driving the
block Wisconsin's known for that yeah I
mean
it's known for that guys man I'm trying
bro you can see me trying as hard as I
can but the power of Castle hates gold
it reminds me like I was expecting to
wear zebra pants yeah all right you want
to hear the description of their podcast
yes sure
Owens constant based podcast that aims
to interview our active military
veterans politicians law enforcement
Community leaders and many others who
are making a direct impact on others but
challenging the status quo
so
it's just a Thin Blue Line show
thick boy Studios is a train wreck that
all 90 000 of us cats are waiting for
this podcast with 22 Subs is perfect
and then the next comment is this is
finally Rock Bottom for Brenda goes on a
podcast with 22 Subs within the first
two minutes he's recycling his crowd
work bits
uh thankfully the cameras far away so
nobody can see Mark's weird strange face
oh my God so everybody commenting is a
[ __ ] hater man and that's cool you
know what I'm doing
because they were wait they came out
nice talking about zuba pants right now
no Sam went to the UFC and all of a
sudden I'm like okay man I gotta tell
you this may be the worst podcast I've
ever heard it's up there I mean buddy
it's in the conversation holy [ __ ] look
you can make your studio look like
Rogan's as much as you want but like
maybe start with the subs first
or a hoagie I don't know what you call
it in Wisconsin
um
Pennsylvania no they're they're in
Wisconsin here no I know but you said
Yogi I know I said I don't know what
they call it in Wisconsin maybe in
Wisconsin they call it a hoagie I don't
know hey Wisconsin what do you call it I
don't [ __ ] know bro
does anybody know anything about that
state geez I know it's next to Minnesota
it's definitely next to Minnesota
and I only know that because of written
house yeah uh I only know that I only
know this seriously I only know that
because on Sundays Mitch used to have to
drive to Wisconsin to buy beer because
of Minnesota's blue loss that's actually
true Scarface bought a beer have you all
seen the Brandon shop Brian Callan Sam
Adams commercial Lewis [ __ ] all over it
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
you need to [ __ ] calm down his dog's
been nuts lately
wait um I'm looking this dog's all
horned up yeah all right my cat's going
through it too I'm looking at them react
wait Brian react to Sam Adams toast
someone commercial
Sam Adams hold on Sam Adams
okay Sam Adams
toast someone
got it got it
so it is a thing yeah it's a real
commercial
what better with than a toast I don't
think that we tell the people we love
enough thank you yeah that's really Sam
Adams I'll throw a picture on Instagram
you're the reason why I've been able to
do this thank you for turning my life
around Redman you brought back that
spark I wouldn't be here without you man
you guys allow me to really follow my
dream I love you cheers bro I want to
toast you cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
that was really homoerotic
all these Comedy Store people just get a
[ __ ] paycheck nowadays we don't have
enough appreciation of our loved ones
yeah this is from Sam Adams
drunk don't drink the beer already hands
you it's spiked is one of the comments
yeah you're really if you if you're any
company that makes drinks
probably no one already by the way what
he's doing is he's drawing boobs he's
not actually writing jokes I know it
looks like he's writing a joke here but
he's just drawing boobs he's drawing
yeah he's drawing a [ __ ]
self-portrait yeah
[Laughter]
save me pay me like your Comedy Store
girls oh [ __ ]
okay
oh [ __ ] that was great thank you thank
you thank you for for telling me that
that was [ __ ] awesome paint me like
your trash Tuesday girls
exactly uh